when your time on season 11 is all said
and done what do you hope you trying to
end my damn please enough
don't even I'm putting that in the
atmosphere and I gonna ant first of all
this is it could end with a crown this
could be there you go now you talking
but when this season is done a crowning
yes a crown like a like a baby a crown
of Chi Chi than a crown is a different
story fifty shade but when season 11 is
all set in back what do you hope The
fans walk away thinking of Vanessa van G
Matteo well I'm I'm just happy and
thankful that if they get to like really
get to know me I hope everyone enjoys
you know regardless of whatever happens
good win and draw or dick your mouth for
sissy-ass
all opulence you own nothing whatever
may happen you know just enjoy it it's a
great show we all live and love the show
so get out the comment stop typing and
enjoy the show
miss fangy you didn't just come back
[ __ ] you came through yeah
sashay away thank you guys now and go
ahead and get my love San Mateo thank
you love ya if you had to sum up your
time on the show with a word maybe -
what would you boil it down - well I
mean I don't like to say these things I
don't like to really brag about myself
but I've been getting nothing but time
legendary so you're asking about me I
think I'm you know I go down in history
as one of the first you know going home
first I kind of broke the the stigma
yeah of leaving person being the worst
thing ever
ren-dono not to all the other ones that
went home first and I anticipate that
happening either but um you know I kind
of feel like even with soldier I told
her that girls don't worry about it
yes now how you fall is how you get up
and it's at the end of the world cuz
look it you have a system gasps and
you're still here and she's a pursued
the first one to come on their face you
gotta fit I'm sure they're blind [ __ ]
with 50 there's just nobody own up to it
is
I'm currently losing you know what speak
your mind and drink your cocktail and
tell RuPaul
then he's out you got a fist I don't
make the whole interview about her she
better come your check that out - sista
but we uplift them speak the truth
mm-hmm not always
we are gonna I would have never said
that did you make some friends for life
out of this group yes of course I loved
each and every one of them for different
reasons and of course you stuck enough
and you know you're stuck there you're
gonna at this point we definitely to be
you have to click up because you can't
go through this whole process without
leaning on somebody you can't be you
know right cold-hearted so of course
yeah we all build friendships or some of
them are stronger sometime you start
kissing that part
[Music]